the aunt of one of two missing Idaho
kids says their mother had recently
become obsessed with the end of the
world seven year old JJ valo
and 17 year old Ty Lee Ryan were last
seen in September that's a few weeks
before their mother Laurie valo
married a man named Chad de Bell who's
written multiple books about doomsday
scenarios the couple is now in Hawaii
Jonathan Vigliotti has been following
this story from Rexburg Idaho as
authorities work to find out what
happened to Joshua JJ valo and Ty Lee
Ryan they're looking into the past of
Chad de Bell now married to the
children's mother Lori valo de Bell
self-published more than 25 books from
this Idaho home many about his brush
with death and the end of the world his
preachings are what first attracted valo
in a skype interview the missing girls
aunt says valo became obsessed with
doomsday scenarios moved to Idaho to be
with de Bell after her previous husband
Charles ballo died of suspicious causes
last summer in Arizona de belles wife
Tammy also died under mysterious
circumstances last fall the sheriff and
Fremont County Idaho is investigating so
there's a chance here that Laurie could
have also played a role in this death
along with Chad oh there is a chance
that that has occurred and one of the
things that we are looking at very
closely last month
authorities confiscated 43 items from
Chad de belles Idaho home including cell
phones journals documents and
medications have there been any signs of
life that you or your colleagues have
found no you would expect parents and
specifically Lori as a mother to be a
little more responsive about what's
going on with her children there has
been no sign of life or death and
without that an investigator tells me
it's all but impossible to bring this
couple back here to Idaho Tammy de
belles body has been exhumed Gail we're
waiting for the results of that autopsy
all right John
and thank you very much Anthony the more
you hear the more ominous yes and
disturbing it is the details stranger in
string for a resolution in that case
sooner rather than later